seamstresses in yangon's Scot Market at
work the Garment industry boomed under a
democratic government growing 500
percent to make up a third of total
exports in 2019
since the pandemic and the military coup
exports have dropped by a quarter
this once busy car showroom has only a
few models on display the big attraction
a domestically produced people carrier
but production has stalled they can't
get the parts they need from overseas
we wish for political stability as well
if there is no stability it is difficult
to operate
U.S sanctions and blacklists have places
in a tough position despite the fact
that we are still permitted to conduct
money transactions in Regional Nations
such as Singapore China Thailand and
Malaysia around Yangon it's easy to spot
the shuttered offices of foreign
businesses
new restrictions have been imposed by
the military on currency exchange and
the local currency has plummeted in
value they want to turn back the clock
but unless you you shut the door
completely unless Myanmar is is distant
from from the rest of the world
um no they they cannot do that because
somehow the economy especially along the
border between Myanmar and Thailand
Myanmar and China business is as usual
boats shuttling Goods across the Moy
River from Thailand carry everything
from cooking oil to expensive Japanese
fruits business is booming because of
shortages inside Myanmar but so are
prices
for many people those prices are
unsustainable huge rises in the cost of
living for Essentials like food and
transport are forcing them into extreme
poverty people in Yangon complain that
since the military coup prices on public
transport have doubled and services have
got even worse
the one sector is booming this year the
Ministry of Agriculture aims to earn a
billion dollars from rice exports to
India and China a nation where one in
four people don't have enough to eat
sending food overseas for government
revenue Tony Chang Al Jazeera Yangon